dispiace ragazzi non poter utilizzare lo
storno nuovo ma oggi abbiamo la giornata
horror e le giornate horror ci sta il
greenstream la finiamo di andare in giro
per la mia io comunque ancora non ho
capito come mai ho una casa che va in
cerchio se ci fate caso vista la miccia
che da stamattina orribile mi fate
uscire da questa casa per favore che
un'ora e mezza e ci sono presi una
teiera la co del demonio morto ieri
palco i miei amici sono finiti nello
stesso casinò la paura di agevolargli a
divorati non lo so non lo so problema
che ha divorato a me la paura figurati
sono svenuta il tutto sto bordello va
bene ma porca di quella vacca porca
porca no stiamo andando in mezzo alle mi
sembra tipo la intro di mister bean
quando che scava in mezzo alla luce ma
che se è così è una lampada cos'è non
capisco dove sto andando esattamente c'è
un tizio veramente brutto che si agirà
in casa mia e io mi devo ritrovare in
una mega scacchiera ottimo si è colorato
il vestito su un cubo di rubik che
sprizza sangue vabbè che cos'è questo
cubo e che ne so poiché te lo risolva
volendo posto col a un po però rotator
rotating che senso
allora non sono male io qualcuni ruby
che però ve lo devi far girare
normalmente non così and black le sue
rischio camera ok era una filastrocca
carino dovuto fare io sto cubo però lei
tutta cagata sotto poverina eva fai bene
cioè effettivamente anche mi cadde
addosso è veramente un bellissimo
personaggio comunque c'è una porta
entraci non ti far domande cioè queste
su filastrocche fai finta che ti abbia
raccontato quei tre porcellini la stessa
cosa
entra nella porta e fori alle palle
fuori ma entro in casa di nuovo
scommetti questo è il mio armadio chiudi
la porta e riaprirà a noi e penso
ritrovarmi dentro casa questo mio
armadio comunque non ci sono inseriti
dentro ed esco ed entro in varie zone
della mia della mia casa ok sta tentando
di punirti in che cosa esattamente c'è
un tizio vibrava sedi sul divano che è
meglio lasciar perdere perché porca
vacca oggi vivono e quando non è
giornata che ti svegli che ti trovi in
mezzo a degli scacchi io proprio la
giornata la prenderei a buttare nel toto
abbiamo capito che non ha senso
continuare
vai a dormire doha d'armi ti svegli
domani che sei a posto
episodio qua c'è lei è rimasta sul
divano
ecco
giorno non riesco a capire che cosa c'è
in questa foto sei tu a rovescio mentre
sta bene cosa degli scalchi lina i soldi
e li na minchia ma che madonna mia che
ansia non riesco a farlo così veloce no
anzi incredibile quindi posso
payen not your friends non sono tuo
amico e kick ass ti vuole ho trovato una
robert è pieno di foto ne guardo una una
randomica anno c'è una rossa guardia
rossa
tu mi stai ancora osservando molto bene
continua sono proprio contento di vedere
se non mi sento solo almeno a c'è
qualcuno che era quindi è una gif non
erano nè radio non era la polaroid era
una jeep che figata se inventassero tipo
le gif delle polaroid tipo harry potter
c'è una porta che sia chiusa e non c'era
una porta prima io
chiudi chiudi chiudi giù di lì che mi
compare il mio corridoio sarebbe stato
troppo bello per essere vero
ok cui la moto on
se ci fate caso sta diventando sempre un
po più aberrante quella fare lì è qua
siamo plastic free comunque non si mette
anche poi vietato un birdie un casino
del demonio ogni volta tra l'altro ogni
volta come se non fosse abituato porca
lesso anche le cose niente non c'è
meglio fino a che non schiato la mia
vita continua infarti va bene non mi si
è staccato il mouse non so per quale
bontà divina tra l'altro giorno c'è la
torcia per terra e c'è qualcuno che sta
uscendo la mia vasca devo prendere la
torcia prima che gli prenda lui fa e
allora sei stupida fatelo dire porca
vacca fatto che l'ho spinta di sotto non
è colpa mia io ci ho provato ma ripreso
no
e non è finita sotto il mobile air
ispezione alla mano ok sentisse a polso
più la madonna taglia delle unghie si sa
quando hai voglia cosa so che cosa è
successo
find the laptop trova il computer eccolo
dalla torcia è tornata di qua dopo che
l'ho spinta occhio che appena la
spunterà il demonio dietro fa fa fa
ragazzi non c'è nessuno che è un
miracolo trovami indovino trova mi hai
visto lo sapevo che prima capito basta
se mi sta scrivendo di continuo ragazzi
trova mia perché sta scrivendo a un
computer video trovare un computer sarà
da qualche parte in casa un altro
computer
qualcosa mi dice che qua però non lo so
a noi dice anche qua pro vandali in
camera mia vediamo cosa succede
una donna di dio che anzi a rivivere va
bene entro qui hai dong edwards what's
happening
e dietro il divano o fuori dalla
finestra satin eye una mano che più
grossa del mio divano come fa a essere
di sotto
beh lasciò la trovatori nel divano
eccoti ma non aver paura
cosa vai sei qua con me ma porca vacca
perché voglio essere vieni qua
ma allora diventa tutto molto più
interessante ma è di lo priva di un
mostro non belosi lina ma no ma che
peccato invano preso bene war is there
allora zio ascolta mi hai rotto il ca te
esci esci da casa mia hai rotto le palle
e uscito il nuovo film dei miei contro
te la vendetta del signore se andiamo a
vederlo basta sari casa basta che devo
fare qua a parte uscire e rientrare
dalle varie porte giorno
c'è qualcuno chiuso nel frigo se uscire
l'altro giorno ma ti puoi pulire la
bocca che mi fa schifo non fare niente
fa niente la sedia che la vita vi
mancava però è un ottimo modo per tenere
per avere più spazio ecco posso uscire
di qua
esco dalla porta esco dalla porta no
esco dall altra porta dove sono entrato
che magari c'è la nostra stanza dietro
esatto ecco ci manca scommetto che raga
ma cosa sta succedendo ma perché minchia
uno specchio mar abbiamo però sta
succedendo continua a dare indietro
senza guardare a prima porta così sono
entrato senza neanche perfetto no
ragazzi avete visto prima con lo sporco
nora che non sto capendo niente di
quello che sta succedendo mi fate andare
mi spieghi qual è il problema
cessata si sta impossessando dei miei
neuroni non lo so vedo robe strane non
che tutto questo fosse dichiaro
effettivamente nello scorso episodio ma
a merano anguria e rana gouriani tentato
di uscire open the oven amica il forno
vanno all'arci che si può chi è che sta
bruciando qua niente a posto veniva già
risolto su di vermi beh figo io avverte
me lo mangerei e c'è un po di appetito
ecco se non ti piacevano buttavi non a
caso di buttare il tavolo per fa
pertanto va bene ragazzi ciò il cervello
che non sta più ragionando da almeno 20
minuti o madonna che schifo mi sembra la
metà tra la silent hill
va bene mi piaci passo preciso che culo
quindi quando ci passo per niente se non
azzecca ok ci passo
qua ci passa pure sul finale nell'undici
passo
eccoci siamo arrivati all'ultimo raga
non lo sono mai morto pazzesco
non avevo visto a te aiuto ce l'ho fatta
sono arrivato sta mai morire è
fantastico ma dirlo subito che sei tu no
un bagno me lo farei
fossi in te ora che sei brutto non è che
deve puzzare fare schifo per forza
qualcuno che mi spiega cosa è successo
ma che è perché ce le braccia nere aiuto
non capisco norica un po è servito così
via ma perché io gioca sta roba perché
perché perché spiegarmi il motivo spiega
mi il motivo
la vita non è
[Musica]